hello I'm Alexa Chung welcome to my
Glamour magazine cover shoot been a
lovely day I've done a collaboration
with M&S marks and sparks and basically
it's an archive collection so it's
called a very mouthy title MLS and the
lexer Chung rediscovers our archive but
essentially it's archived by Alexa and
what I did was I went to Leeds which is
where their archive is actually it's
very glamorous and then cherry-picked
everything in there I thought even
though it was made from you know ranging
from 1884 to the present day
things that made sense in the context of
2016 I do so much vintage shopping that
being led into the archive was sort of
like having access to the best rift shop
ever I genuinely loved more pieces and
you know it's where you go for your gray
cashmere v-neck jumbo or you might
borrow your dad's shirt for a painting
class then nowadays that would look very
saline and I think the idea behind this
thing was I already recognized how
relevant that brand is today just from
things I've borrowed from my mom or
dad's wardrobe and I was like where have
those pieces gone would it be amazing if
there was actually a million more of
those things around that we haven't been
able to unearth
so it's kind of like a fashion
excavation and really fun on this very
shoot today I just named the collection
because I asked yesterday what things
were called no like jumper trousers I
wish you could in the name and I
realized because MLS started as a market
stall in 1884 it would be nice to see
what the most popular names of that year
were so then I named the collection
after those names of crop tops so I'm
about to introduce you to some pretty
strong old lady names so this is ADA ADA
suit these trousers I love and we didn't
have to even touch the pattern it was
literally the perfect fit so the only
thing was they were in canary yellow
which is nice but I thought perhaps
you'd appreciate it if I toned it down a
bit so yeah other than that the fit is
identical and as soon as I put more I
was like oh my god they're so they just
remind me of Celine
which is quite cool and then separately
from the trouser we found the blazer
which I guess is kind of an 80s piece so
those would have been presumably the
forties I think actually no you do want
their word 70s the canary-yellow onto it
from 70 and this was more 80s but
together it's made this like super luxe
kind of slouchy suit which I thought was
quite Brian Perry or something this is
called Harry actually you know so the
popular name was Harriet but I thought
it seemed quite royal so I've gone for
Harry this is Prince Harry basically um
I love this actually this might actually
be my favorite thing this was taken from
a photo so in Leeds they have a lot of
multimedia kind of stock so it's not
just the clothes themselves in the
archive it's all of the in-house
magazines a lot of their advertising
some of the TV commercials running as
well so it's it's actually an exhibition
that the public can visit but obviously
there's another layer where you have
more access and this was in a photograph
it's an amazing photograph from like
late 70s early 80s of two women sort of
standing like this and it's perfect we
couldn't see the back so we have to
imagine what that might look like so we
added buttons with all those suited the
kind of Victoriana thighs I just think
is very chic lovely this again as well
Elsie was exactly as is to the point
where the fabric is pretty 60s that kind
of nylon II synthetic thing because I
loved that it added that kind of Swing
equality to it and also we thought as
much as the British spring summer is
spring summer it's also for me
synonymous with festivals I kept
imagining people wearing that with welly
boots for us so nice Effie is an old
friend of mine but Effie just reminds me
of firstly my version of this
unfortunately was brown at my school
that's what I had to wear brown to brown
school uniform and it couldn't be it had
to be this length we obviously stood do
the classic roll up rolling it up
getting out the car rolling it up and
then running into class oh they won't
notice I've taken up 20 inches but who
knew that actually the nicer version was
long they were quite right all along
1980 whatever yes that assistance this
is Myrtle I love this so nice and I will
say we found this from a picture as well
it had kind of a cowl-neck so I did you
all a favor and lopped it off sorry we
tried to make it like that it was kind
of the fabric so tight and I think
everyone would have died of heat
exhaustion this camisole is good Hasse
love who doesn't love it
easy peasy and Bertha which is my school
cardigan reimagined in a blue hue
because as I say it was brown so I
finally got my revenge I've got school
uniform I always wished for I love Percy
pigs